Mạnh không tắc gấu dục nào tạo, hỗ trợ phát triển xin kế sau việc làm win bứng và thúc đại hoàn nhập cộng đồng.
Bối số đối tượng yêu thế, chuyển từ kíu trợ tình thế, sang chủ động phong người trình bị sẵn sang của nước cao phải năng chống chữ.
Cột cà cậu đồng.
Pòi cân thăm ra xuân và khoảng trị dù dó, dựa và cậu đồng.
Sây dựa hẹn thống tại báo sớm, được lợp ứng phó tại trộm, mặt lưới xơ cấp kíu và các mua hình cộng đồng ăn quan.
Mỗi xã át của anh đã khu cần tương buất của đổi mũ tình đường, viên đã khuến đợp của phương ăn hình đạo của khả năng hỗ trợ kìa trời các giống rế bị tổn tương.
Nhất là chế em người cao tuổi người quyết tập người mất bệnh hiện ngào của người dân hủng xấu của người dưới hại đạo.
Yếu trợ hình cấp, giám vô ý phục hồi nhà án mức xãi, chăm sóc xức hồi hỗ trợ tâm lý khôi phục xin kế và tái thiết tổn đồng.
Trong kíu trợ, quan đồng hội vốn phản tiếp tục đồng hành để người dân thực sự ở định của sống,
cùng vũ yếu phó thiên đài của n注 bị tốt hơn, chứ các giữ gòn ý tế cộng đồng tay nào và khung hạn xức hỏi tinh thần.
Mỗi trường học, cơ quan nhà mấy và cộng đồng cần có thêm người được chăm mị,
kiến năng xơ cấp kiú bồi đây là năng lực tiếp tục có thể kíu sống con người trong những phút đầu tiên của tay nào và các sự cố.